qué número le tienes que agregar a equis
cuadrada menos 6x para completar el
trinomio al cuadrado perfecto entonces
yo lo que quiero es buscar el trinomio
al cuadrado perfecto agregándole a x
cuadrada menos 6x algún número por lo
tanto lo primero que quiero hacer es
para que no se pierda toda esta
información
escribirlo aquí abajo x cuadrada menos
6x y quiero completar este binomio
cuadrado perfecto x cuadrado menos 6x
más algo me va a dar un binomio al
cuadrado perfecto o dicho de otra manera
esto va a ser un trinomio cuadrado
perfecto y la pregunta es qué número le
tengo que agregar para que en efecto sea
un trinomio al cuadrado perfecto y bueno
antes de irme a resolver esto me
gustaría que recordáramos un poco cómo
se veían las expresiones de la forma x
más ha elevado al cuadrado bueno esto lo
mismo déjame ponerlo de otro color esto
va a ser lo mismo
x más ha elevado al cuadrado que x más a
por x más a recuerdas cuando no te sabes
perfectamente la expresión equivalente
puedes poner x + a por x + a y resolver
esta multiplicación de binomios
hay que multiplicar x masa por el otro x
+ am y bueno x x x x cuadrada después me
queda x x am que me da a x x x que me da
también a x y después me queda a por a
que me da a cuadrado y una vez que
seamos ya esta operación lo que hacíamos
era fijarnos en la parte derecha de esta
ecuación para pensar en reducir términos
comunes por ejemplo aquí tenemos a x x y
entonces me queda x cuadrada más dos
veces a x más a cuadrada y esto es justo
la fórmula o la expresión equivalente
que nos dan cuando nosotros elevamos un
binomio al cuadrado perfecto y de hecho
a esta expresión se le conoce como un
trinomio cuadrado perfecto entonces si
te das cuenta tenemos a x cuadrada
tenemos dos veces a x eso es lo que
queremos es decir el número que está al
lado de la x vamos a querer que sea 2 am
y nos falta agregarle el cuadrado de a
es decir lo que queremos es aumentarle a
esta expresión que tengo aquí el
cuadrado de amd y para sacar a necesito
fijarme primero en quién es dos veces am
es decir me voy a fijar siempre 100
siempre que me pidan completar el
trinomio cuadrado perfecto en el número
que está al lado de la equis en este
caso es el menos 6 y ya que tengo el
menos 6 lo que voy a hacer es decir que
este es dos veces am o en su dado caso
sacarle la mitad como ustedes quieran
pero bueno voy a decir que dos veces a
es igual a menos seis o dicho de otra
manera lo único que hay que hacer es
sacar la mitad a menos seis para que nos
dé el valor de amd a es igual a menos 3
menos 6 entre 2 es menos 3 y entonces
aquí tengo que escribir el cuadrado de
amd para que esto sea un tren o metro
cuadrado perfecto hay que agregarle el
cuadrado de amd y el cuadrado de menos
39 positivo es decir este 9 que acabo de
agregar es cuadrada y si ya tengo a
cuadrada entonces ya tengo x cuadrada
más dos veces el primero por el segundo
más el cuadrado del segundo es decir
este ya es un trinomio al cuadrado
perfecto deja de escribir lo que es
cuadrada menos 6 x más 9 a quien es
equivalente a ver dos números que
multiplicados medie 9 y que sumados me
den menos 6 pues es x menos 3 por x
menos 3 estás de acuerdo
o dicho de otra manera es x
elevado al cuadrado y ya con esto
obtengo que este binomio al cuadrado
perfecto me da este trinomio cuadrado
perfecto